[موسيقى]
رمضان في لبنان يحل الشهر الفضيل هذا
العام وشط ازمه ماليه القت بثقلها على
حياه معظم اللبنانيين ازمه غير مسبوقه
وصفها البنك الدولي بانها واحده من اعماق
حالات الكساد في التاريخ الحديث
[تصفيق]
هنا في سوق صبر الشعبي في بيروت يشعر
الناس بالاعباء التي فرضها التضخم في
البلاد وهم يتسوقون خلال شهر رمضان
الغلاء الفاحش لاسعار المواد الغذائيه
والاستهلاكيه طر عددا كبيرا من اللبنانيين
الى تغيير عادات التسوق
هاي اول مره بتاريخ حياتنا العالم تاره
هلا بالحبه
في بلد يستورد سته وثمانين في المئه من
مواده الغذائيه بلغت نسبه التضخم
139 في المئه وفقا لاحدث ارقام البنك
الدولي منعكس على اسعار السلع والمواد
الاستهلاكيه والغذائيه ومنها اللحوم
والخضروات والاسماك من اربع خمس سنين
اختلف كل الوضع يعني كنا ببلد وصرنا ببلد
يعني يا لطيفه وين رايحين بعد يعني هذا
السمك
صرنا نجيب ثلاثه اربعه اصناف
راس السمك
ترتفع الاسعار اكثر من مره في اليوم
الواحد تماشيا مع صعود الدولار الامريكي
بعد ان باتت جميع السلع تشعر بالدولار او
بما يقابله من الليره اللبنانيه التي فقدت
اكثر من
98% من قيمتها مقابل العمله الامريكيه
وضع اثر على عادات معظم الفئات اللبنانيه
التي تعاني من الغلاء الفاعش لاسعار
اغلبيه المواد الاستهلاكيه
عم نحط مليون مليونين وما في ما بيعطي ولا
الواحد بده يجيب تبدلت العادات كثيرا
خصوصا مع غلاء الاسعار وتدني القدره
الشرائيه للناس وارتفاع معطل الفقر سفره
رمضان التي كثيرا ما كانت مليئه باصناف
متعدده من الاطعمه التي تتقدم تقليديا
وجبات الافطار تغيب عن موائد اللبنانيين
في رمضان بسبب ارتفاع تكلفتها